à la sortie de la salle d'audience le
jeune homme à l'air soulagé son avocat
détendu peu après l annonce du verdict
c'est quand même une décision
satisfaisante on part de loin il y avait
cent mille euros qui était demandé si on
cumule toutes les demandes de dommages
et intérêts au final on arrive à peine
vingt mille euros six mois
d'emprisonnement avec sursis
c'est ce qu'un tribunal aurait dans un
dossier j'ai envie de dire qu'il n'avait
pas été médiatisée très certainement
prononcé la mise à l'épreuve
voilà la mise à l'épreuve elle peut se
discuter c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est sur ce point là qu'on veut
envisager l'opportunité ou pas lundi
c'était le 29 septembre dernier
ce trentenaire furieux de ne pas être
remboursés de la salle de son téléphone
tombé en panne se rend dans l'app store
de la toison d'or
il détruit plusieurs appareils à l'aide
d'une boule de pétanque
son geste est filmé et vue plus de 11
millions de fois sur internet
aujourd'hui à la barre il explique qu'il
se sentait humilié
même s'il reconnaît que son action était
disproportionnée il avait contacté le
service commercial de la marque
plusieurs dizaines de fois sans jamais
obtenir de réponse les avocats d'apple
eux précise que le dijonnais est loin du
robin des bois qu'il prétend être
depuis 2000 on sait le cinquième
appareil qui demande à se faire
remplacer ou remboursé par la marque
également partie civile dans ce dossier
le vigile il sera indemnisé pour ce
geste agressif du jeune homme
c'est finalement un jugement mesuré qu'à
rendu le tribunal correctionnel de dijon
de la prison certes mais intégralement
couvertes par un sursis les juges ont
évité l'écueil de la peine exemplaire
les parties ont désormais dix jours pour
faire appel